our twenty-fifth charity day was
December last year and the firm
obviously split I cap split from next
which is a part that I ran and this is
the first we're calling it the next
giving day so there's no confusion
perhaps and we are giving away our days
revenue which will be approximately been
about two million pounds there are six
charities we're supporting in in London
this year
mental health is one of the issues that
we are trying to focus on heads together
as a fairly one of the key charities
were promoting also some other
conservation ones Blumarine local
charities all the charities regionally
the office in New York will support
American charities Singapore Singaporean
Charities Stockholm Tel Aviv now you're
in the process of selling next to CMA
they should call go Mercantile Exchange
will this fantastic event continue under
the new owners the CME have said they
kept their own charity program but they
have committed certainly to pursuing the
charity day again next year and I hope
when the businesses will get together
I'll be on the board of the CNE maybe
they'll continue it in its same format
but one way or another they are
certainly committed to material support
of charitable causes and charitable
principles you were a big supporter of
the remain campaign why are you so
confident that the city is going to
retain retain its preeminence post
brexit a lot of people are very scared
why am i optimistic because you know
what London has got strength and depth
and financial services that is proven
over not just a year or two but over
decades even centuries and France and
Paris I should say and Frankfurt have
never been global financial centers the
Germans frankly have never particularly
aspired towards it they obviously have a
great industrial base manufacturing and
technology and they do that
exceptionally well and they've never
really wanted to foster Frankfurt as a
global financial center the French now
represent that they have great
aspirations to turn Paris into a
financial center and I if I might say I
think have gone quite actively about
attempting to take services from London
for example euro clearing I personally
think they will fail
what do you think the city really needs
to hear from the PM in terms of brexit
negotiations Europe you know we import a
hell of a lot of cars from Germany and
from France and many other things too so
it is in the vested interests of both
Europe and the UK in my opinion to come
to a sensible deal unfortunately you get
the sensation that there are those in
Europe who actually visibly want to see
the UK damaged as a result of this
process what about the state of the
markets right now it's very interesting
you've seen bond yields creeping higher
both in the United States and
particularly in Europe especially over
the last few days speculation that the
ECB's going to rein in its asset
purchases unwind quantitative easing is
this the the end of the great bond bull
market yes you want my personal opinion
we have seen the end of the great bond
bull market and we haven't yet had a
return of inflation but we have had a
slight upward tick of inflation we have
had a 30-year bull market in fixed
income instruments indeed as you very
well know we have in recent years even
had negative interest rates in some
intention in the ten-year maturity on
some government bonds I mean that is
historically unprecedented and I think
that that extraordinary period is now
behind us the the financial crisis which
has echoed for a lot longer than many of
us would like through our economic life
is now I think beginning to fade I'm not
saying it's gone completely from our
memories I doubt it will but so I think
we are beginning we are now definitely
in the transition back to a more normal
interest rate environment where
ultimately you will get yield curves and
by the way I think for that reason as
well my own views we are probably you
know around and about the peak of the
great bull market too